you
if you're thinking of migrating or
writing your next application on
postgres we've got an awesome database
for you
alloy DB is a Google Cloud database with
full postgres compatibility that scales
in any direction you need up down out or
in to handle any workload you throw at
it
okay back up for a sec why are postgres
compatible database if I want postgres
shouldn't I just run postgres
of course you can and many people do
open source Technologies Drive the
application development world because of
their Innovation their wealth of shared
knowledge and their welcoming and
engaged communities
so what exactly do we mean when we say
ladb is compatible with open source
postgres
first of all it's based on the postgres
Kernel it supports every new major
version that comes out and we update
minor versions and security patches
during maintenance and speaking of
Maintenance just to slip this in only
briefly interrupts rights and doesn't
interrupt reads at all
second it's wire compatible any client
that you use to talk to an out of the
box postgres instance will also talk to
alloy DB whether it's psql PG admin or
an application you've written on top of
postgres they'll all just work
and third alloy DB has extensive support
for postgres extensions there's a good
chance that the ones that you use will
work as is the biggest takeaway is that
if you're familiar with postgres you can
start using alloy DB without any changes
your databases and applications will be
fully portable between alloy DB and
other postgres databases wherever you
choose to run them
but when your application is so awesome
that hordes of new users are at your
door you need to figure out scalability
and reliability fast in other words you
need the full power of the cloud and
allo ADB delivers it uses the Cloud's
massive compute and storage resources to
deliver high performance and
availability it offers Global
deployments automatic database tuning
automated scaling and load balancing
analytics and AIML Integrations and so
much more
and that's what it means to be fully
compatible with postgres and enjoy the
openness and portability of Open Source
with a scalability and intelligence of
the cloud
so go ahead get a charge out of Google
Cloud without compromising your
commitment to postgres move your data
build your applications and just watch
what a super powered postgres database
can do
available on Google Cloud create an
instance today and connect your
application there are links to the
documentation and getting started guides
in the description below